forty years ago in Iran leaders of the
so-called Islamic Revolution banned
women football fans from attending
matches women are still allowed to enter
the stadium as players however and now
Iran's national team of women under the
age of 19 is one of the best in Asia the
team is coached by an American Iranian
who believes her players are starting a
revolution of their own I wanted to make
history in an Islamic country where
women who are so talented to be able to
become you know top top football country
in the rankings previously you know it
was considered taboo and eventually you
know whenever the officials and the and
whatnot we're seeing you know women who
were taking such interest in this they
were letting down a lot of their guards
so I just honestly I find a location on
an Iran and I'm going there this week
and I just end up with you know walking
through the streets to the parks to the
schools and I try to find my players
that way so you know very very
traditional but I have actually found
one of my best players playing in a park
with her uncle's and her brothers you
know she was beating everybody up and
I'm like you are coming back with me and
you know the father is fortunately they
love the fact that their daughters are
can play soccer now or football so for
them it's a it's like yeah take my
daughter and make her into the next you
know superstar because we're a football
nation they didn't want their daughters
to be involved and you know now we have
you know we started with 40 players now
we have over like 4,000 football select
players in in Iran just a good start
I was warned the u.s. I'm American Union
but you know here they don't look at it
that way they just say okay the the
foreign girl but you got in day I'm very
Iranian at the same time very American
so I tried to bring best of my both
worlds together young you know I have a
very strict system a set in place
because I want the girls not just to
come here to play football I want them
to also have a future in whatever they
like they wake up very early they train
twice or even three times a day and they
have to take care of themselves and this
is something that if you I can teach
them they will teach their friends and
their friends will teach knows and so on
so I want that domino effect to happen
throughout the entire country just a few
months ago we were able to enter the
stadium see Iran which is Bolivia see
the Asian Championships and what not I
think this is a good step you know it's
something that we can fight for but in
general I think internationally we need
to be recognized as not the country that
doesn't allow women to the stadiums but
as a country that you know they they're
ninjas and they're fighting and you know
they they're really improving in their
football skills and you know they're
enhancing in every social level as well
and it's helped with the development of
a country so you know III want these
girls to you know either next ministers
that hopefully the president you know to
be the mayor of governors of their their
side and to help not just football grow
but to help you know women grow as a
whole